[Music]
on the second floor of humble brick
building in Brooklyn New York a small
biotech company is working on a product
that could revolutionize emergency
medicine
it's called vetti gel and it can stop
traumatic bleeding almost instantly
we're definitely hoping that this can
change the way the world looks at wound
care not only stopping bleeds but being
able to treat burns we could even apply
this technology into the regeneration of
organs one day my name is joel angelina
and i'm the CEO here and it's nurse the
company started about four years ago
when i was a freshman at NYU I had the
idea I would suppose to use a polymer to
seal up a wound very quickly in the
beginning I wasn't expecting with the
polymer itself would be able to quickly
stop bleeds we realized that if we put
it onto a wound something really
remarkable would happen which is that it
would actually change shape it would
change color and it would interact with
the tissue and in a way that wasn't
expected this is a video Joe and his
team shot early in the development
process
that's actual blood being pumped through
a piece of liver
vetti gel is applied and the bleeding
stops
that was the moment that showed we were
on to something much bigger than we
thought we were very gently so effective
because it works in tandem with the
body's natural healing processes in a
way that hasn't been tried before the
Jail visit up of plant drug polymers
that's what we do is we extract pieces
of the cell walls out of the plant
kind of like Lego blocks
I when applied to a womb these Lego
blocks will actually reassemble onto
whatever you put them next to so if you
put it on to the skin it'll reassemble
into the pattern of the skin and with
that you can get a very fast and very
durable platform so this is a location
in the lab where you're able to test the
efficacy of what you are creating
absolutely the challenge now for the
saneras team is to fine-tune vetti gel
into a market ready fda-approved product
so it can actually start saving lives at
this station they're measuring how
quickly vetti gel wants blood so whole
blood versus blood with our product as
you can see we're already getting that
natural spike we've already caught it in
a really short period of time so what
does this mean
for its application in the real world
let's say there was you know a soldier
who was shot on the battlefield he has
three minutes to live he's bleeding out
of his femoral artery the next leading
competitor can stop a bleed and say five
to ten minutes but he's only got those
three you apply this in 15 seconds time
you can ensure that not only will the
bleeding stop but it'll remain stopped
due to the high cloud strength
vetti gel is about to make its real
world debut as a product for the
veterinary market and it will have to
prove safe and effective for animals if
it's ever going to be approved for human
use but Joe fully expects that his
technology will eventually become
ubiquitous in healthcare really our goal
is to get this in every ambulance and
every soldier's belt and in every mom's
purse and really the in every mom's
purse means having a product that is
easy enough to be used but I just spent
anybody the folks behind Betty Gel know
that they have a long road ahead of them
any new medical breakthrough does it's
going to be a ton of time in a mountain
of paperwork before what they're
devising can be used on human beings but
should that time come what we see here
isn't just some esoteric tool that can
be added to a surgeon's kit this might
just be the band-aid of the future
[Music]